Patt forties said to join us here and he
covers college football college
basketball for Sports Illustrated senior
writer there he joins us from Louisville
good morning how are you bad okay
awesome I just brought up this great
recruit the Monty Bates out of Michigan
he's a sophomore and I'm wondering can a
shoe company lock him up now as a
sophomore in high school depending what
the like Michigan high school basketball
rules are maybe you know certainly under
the table they can as they have been
doing for the last community but you
know if you want to give him the fifty
million dollar contract then you'd have
to go aboveboard there and now that's
thing if this prep school that he's
going to is not going to play by
Michigan High School Athletic
Association rules might be a whole
different deal you might be able to
throw the money on the table for him now
and then the next question is name image
and likeness if he's going to go to
Michigan State if the two percent chance
actually happens you know what can he
accept via a name of gelatinous or what
could he not accept oh I don't think
he's gonna end up in Michigan State man
his dad started this prep school so his
dad's his coach there but you know if
I'm Nicky is is a Michigan State in Nike
school I believe okay so if I'm like II
why don't I just put his parents on
payroll as consultants and pay them you
know fifty million dollars over the next
five years well I guarantee they're
earning on payroll as consultants the
question is yeah how much
versus you know a straight out monster
deal directly to their son but but
there's no doubt that Nike was was
paying them for the base fundamentals
team that they had in the AAU circuit
the last couple of years and they will
pay for this prep school you know what
the consulting fee there and then
eventually yeah the big money's coming
again I just don't know whether they're
ready you know to give a 16 year old 50
million dollars if it were me I wait
until he's like 18 and I've seen his
progression continue the ways been I
mentioned the Ivy League is is pondering
the idea of spring football and I don't
know where we're gonna
be in the spring and fit how different
it's gonna be in the fall but your
thoughts on the Ivy League doing this
well I mean I'd say pay attention
because remember they were the first
ones to cancel on basketball and
everybody thought oh my gosh that's
extreme they're you know they're
overreacting now they were right they
were ahead of everybody else and I think
people will pay attention to what
they're doing around college sports
nobody wants to go to spring but it's a
possible safety net I think there's more
and more people that are open to it now
than they were a month ago you know and
I think that gosh we've kind of kept
kicking the can down the road ban for a
few weeks now like well let's wait till
July first we're getting close to July
1st doesn't look very good we better
wait till July 15th but I think there
will be serious discussions in the next
couple of weeks about what if what do we
do if we just don't think that we can
safely bring back players bring back
students have College is normal in the
fall maybe we do look at the spring
boomer esiason the former NFL
quarterback works for CBS he has a
morning show in New York and WFAN he
floated out the idea or possibility that
maybe all of these kids are testing
positive and that might be more
strategic at the you know the high level
in college football your thoughts on
that I mean it would not completely
shock me especially you know like
Clemson where I don't think demos
sweetie is the guy that's running around
like saying we really need to respect
the virus I think it's more the other
way around so he might be saying yeah
let's get it all out of the way now as
supposed to have an eight guys test
positive the week we play Notre Dame and
not be able to play them you know that's
a very risky approach obviously you know
if you talked infectious disease experts
and health experts they're gonna say no
this is really not a very good idea not
you know being able to ensure that all
health side effects of this are going to
be minor and everybody's going to come
back and be perfectly fine and you're
not going to spread it to coaches and
support personnel and eventually
professors and all that sort of thing so
it would be a very risky strategy but
what I wouldn't shock me completely not
Phillip Fulmer the athletic director of
Tennessee is planning on
100,000 fans for football games in the
fall I'm gonna take the under on that
Pat well this recruiting class though
they got a good freak routing class here
nobody's gonna have a hundred thousand
sir I mean the things would have to
change so radically and I know this has
changed significantly as we've gone
along but for the next two months things
would have to just absolutely turn on a
dime and right now we're going the other
direction from that so maybe if you're
very lucky you play football and then
you get twenty thirty forty thousand in
there you have a radical realignment
plan for college football I do you want
explain it give me the Cliff Notes
version here yes the 40 Bowl Subdivision
basically every conference is fractured
you remake them as 1012 team conferences
a 120 teams totally you kick out 11 you
bring in North Dakota State you move
them up every one of the ten conference
champions gets an automatic bid to a 12
team playoff you had two at-large teams
you play for four teams get a bye
eight teams play on college campuses
first round quarterfinals on college
campuses then Sammy's and championship
as normal and you basically you you are
much more regionally oriented here you
know instead of having West Virginia
going to Lubbock and vice versa the
conference's are much more aligned so
that student-athletes don't have to
travel as far and schools don't have to
pay as much to do the traveling what
kind of reaction have you gotten some
people love it some people hate it
generally if you are an establishment
area and you've already got everything
like Notre Dame done want to be in the
congressman Notre Dame hates the fact
that I want to put him in a conference
Florida and Georgia do not want to be in
a conference with Florida Atlantic and
Georgia Southern
but in my deal they are now if you're
Georgia Southern you're like yeah bring
it on bring the dogs down to Statesboro
let's play them so it just kind of
depends on your point of view who would
USC be in with
USC would be in the West Coast
Conference which would be most of the
pac-12 over plus you're you're kicking
out Arizona Arizona State Utah and
Colorado and you're putting in like San
Diego State Fresno State
Hawaii and Nevada then they would be the
literal 12 westernmost schools to play
FPS yeah I wondered if we would get to
the point where that we would have the
five the power five and you would just
leave it at that and you just say let's
secede from the union here and we have
our own college football program you
have a commissioner
you know five twelve team conferences
yeah and maybe I have an a-team or ten
team playoff what do you what do you
think about that proposal they're not
going to they probably just as soon
separate from the American Athletic
Conference in the great mayor or the
Midwest and the Mac and all that but
still that you know the one thing they
don't want they want to take the NCAA
structure with them so that somebody is
in charge of hosting championships and
some and putting them on and story is in
charge of beating the bad guy cuz none
of them want to be the bad guy they
don't want to police if anything they'd
rather have the n-c-double-a doing it
effectively and then blame them for
being ineffective so the NCAA does exist
for a reason but the power v Breaking
Away is more likely unfortunately than
my superior plan House morale uh you
know good enough good enough keep it
going you know let's just one day at a
time and let's see what we can possibly
get to by the time school starts what's
the first game that you're scheduled to
go to I am NOT scheduled right now for
anything I went to the Belmont Stakes
and read that is all I have on my Play
we've got a meeting later this week to
kind of see where we're going to get if
we're going to go to uh two games but
we'll go from there I would imagine you
know kicking the Kentucky Derby is on
Labor Day weekend so I would cover that
but I would probably be football games
that Thursday and made even maybe
monday that Labor Day if there are
football games and we deem it safe to
travel I got a book for you when it
comes out right Thompson wrote it and
and it's about Pappy Van Winkle it's
about work it's about horse racing and
Pappy Van Winkle and I got an advance
copy and read it it's wonderful I mean
because right Thompson is he's not one
of the best sports writers he's one of
the best writers out there and I figured
that you being in Louisville
you'd have great appreciation for that
and maybe you've had Pappy Van Winkle
before I have had some Pappy cross my
lips so you can mine right and Pappy
Thank You Pat good to talk to you and
we'll talk soon thank you at Pat 40
Sports Illustrated senior writer